Vetting is really down to you.
It's really personal
around whether or not you've had some criminal
convictions,
whether or not you've had any
involvement with the police at all,
perhaps as a witness or a victim.
What I would say to you is
just please make sure that
when we ask specific questions on the vetting forms,
that you answer the question that's given.
Cause a lot of the time
people may fail veteran
because they don't give
the correct level of information that's required.
So if we say,
have you been a witness,
have you been a victim?
Do you have a criminal conviction?
If the answer that is yes, say yes.
Don't look and think,
I don't want to say that
because that will make me look bad,
because actually
it might not be as bad as you think.
And what will happen is
our vetting officers will have a look at those details
and that information that we have
via a lot of intelligence checks
that we can do around you,
your family,
where you live,
what you've been involved in,
and if there are kind of low level offenses that will
perhaps were committed when you're a juvenile,
or have a look at the circumstances of those.
So vetting at the moment,
it's not black and white.
It's really,
really down to your individual circumstances.
So what I would say is
as anything in the police
or anything that you do,
be entirely honest
and Disclose everything.
Because at least that way
we know the information.
And it looks like you're telling us the truth.
Um, because you may think.
Actually, I don't want to say that.
And it makes you look like
you're trying to hide things from us.
And actually,
as an organisation,
we're really keen,
um, on getting the full information
and the truth about what's happened
to make sure that we can save god, the public